Nick starts us off in Massachusetts hi
Nick how are you hi Dave how you doing
better than I deserve sir how can I help
well I'd like to say I'm a new newly
been exposed to your program on YouTube
and have enjoyed watching the various
topics I one thing that stuck out to me
is we seem very opposed to people
leasing or as you like to say
leasing vehicles and I wanted to get
your perspective on if there's ever
situations that you think it may be in
someone's interest to do so and I mean
it from the standpoint of say I'm going
to lease a Honda Civic or you know it's
true zero down payment of you know 150
160 dollars months you know my car
expenses are then fixed they don't have
to worry about you know disposals of you
know residual values of the car that
that's all you know that that's all sort
of bacon and all of that risk is off the
table do you still think that it's
better to procure a used vehicle and
being subject to costly repairs and then
eventually not knowing the full cost
until you get rid of the car at a later
date and time mathematically it has to
be or Honda is losing money on the
transaction with you on average and
Honda is not losing money on the
transaction with you on average they're
not stupid okay because I know I know
that you hear what I just said yeah no I
get it so if you drive their car for
four years and a four-year lease and you
hand it back to them 100% of the time
unless they have screwed something up
royally either they have you know you
have not you've limited your risk on
depreciation because you've guaranteed
you're going to pay the maximum
depreciation in your payment about three
years ago and I mean I understand sort
of how how the least how the leasing
works but I mean I had great luck
leasing the Nissan Leaf you know an
all-electric vehicle paying 125 a month
with crew zero down and you know when I
turned it in the residual value was
below where I was I mean I know electric
cars are still new the technology is
evolving the depreciation function
difference in both cars but you know
it's ended up being look let's talk
about that okay if that happens if they
do a thousand of those and they lose
money on every one of those transactions
what you're saying is is the value of
the car was less than your residual
value by far right correct grin so that
means they lost they take that car then
from you and they sell it at a loss if
they do that thousands of times they're
out of business well I know since then
they've adjusted the residual on do you
see what I'm saying mathematically a
lease has to be designed where they make
money on all areas of the transaction it
has to be they don't give you they don't
you know they're not an altruistic
organization they're not there to bless
you my son they are there to take your
freaking money and so you're using their
car you're using their capital and
you're going to pay a cost of capital
and you're going to turn the car back in
and they're going to make money on the
back end on the front end and on the
monthly and if they don't they're going
to go out of business
at least tell you man General Motors
Lexus on two there are a lot of things
but when it comes to crunching numbers
on the depreciation of a vehicle and
building that into your fleece payment
100 % man they're not going to screw
that up they're very good at what they
do and if you're under the illusion that
on average you're going to make money
off of these guys then you just think
you're not running your calculator
properly huh it's impossible I get I
just worried you know I mean I I'm in
the market okay you do whatever you want
you asked and I told you that's how it
works okay I'm going to argue with you
anymore hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]